todd gurley has seen an increase in his
production and his opportunities in
recent weeks 28 touches against the the
bears 20 this past weekend against the
cardinals and you know it's caused some
to think that as we get closer to the
end of the season and the rams get
closer elimination chris that the time
has come to unleash gurley and not worry
about that knee and
uh sean mcvay the coach of the la rams
was asked that specific question as to
why we have seen in recent weeks an
increase in opportunities for todd
gurley here's what mcveigh had to say
yesterday afternoon
me not being an idiot
you know no i think he's felt good were
you trying to keep him fresh for later
in the season
in case there was a play out front
no no it had nothing to do with that it
was really just
you're just kind of working through the
2019 season the best way to utilize all
of our players and and figuring out what
our identity is and i think we're still
working through that but didn't have
anything to do with you know you know
shoot we're we're just trying to win a
game
i screwed up the throw as i often do
mcvay's response was to the question of
why have we seen more from todd gurley
and what's the reason for it he said me
not being an idiot and look here's the
thing we're not idiots chris of course
this is load management of todd gurley
of course that's why we haven't seen him
as much and it's almost like there's
this unwritten rule among the rams media
and the rams coaching staff to not talk
about todd gurley's knee because todd
gurley is very sensitive about any
discussion about his knee remember
during training camp when he said stop
putting bad juju on my knee yeah like
we're not we're gonna pretend the knees
fine that has nothing to do with any of
it we're just stupid okay todd it's not
because we're trying to protect you
against another injury we're just too
dumb to recognize that we should be
using the 2017 offensive player of the
year more extensively than we are i mean
i don't buy it chris i don't think you
buy it either i don't think anybody buys
no definitely there's issues with his
knee
listen you can go back and watch the
cardinals game last week he's limping
towards the end of the game he had two
runs where he made cuts in the backfield
and his leg gave out and one of them he
fell down the other one he kind of
hopped along and got a few more yards i
think the rams were of course trying to
do load management
totally right because you know they're
just not sure how long he's going to
last but i think here that maybe maybe
recently or maybe last week they finally
just said listen we got to play them and
we got to run them and we're just going
to run them into the ground i mean we're
paying them a lot of money and they're
just going to go with it i mean if he
wants to play football let's give them
the ball and go we can't worry about
saving them for for two years from now
and i think that's probably where they
got to the point of of last week and
they got to some other things that you
know i feel like they've been maybe
missing a little bit in their offense
you know as far as
last week a lot of screens and the
bootleg game came back all enforced and
we talked about it a little yesterday
where it's a year where they got away
with got away from some of that at times
and became past happy and shotgun happy
and all of that so uh uh yeah there's a
lot of things going on there with the
rams but i think with gurley they just
finally said the hell with it let's
throw him out there and let's make him a
workhorse and just see how the the the
knees stands the test of time
yeah i mean look they are paying this
guy so much money and you're right at
some point you've just got to say
we're we're trying to chase a playoff
berth in the nfc we've kept this guy
kind of on ice all year long and now
it's time to just throw him out there
and see what he can do and the knee
either holds up or it doesn't but you
know if it holds up and we don't go to
the playoffs who cares
they're doing everything they can to try
to climb over the vikings and get that
number six seed and it would be helpful
if they had a todd gurley who wasn't
having knee issues but i i fully expect
them to keep using him and i expect to
see a lot of them on sunday night
against the seahawks and uh you know
maybe he makes a difference maybe he
doesn't the last time they played the
seahawks they remember he ended up with
a quad injury and he missed the next
week's game right but uh uh yeah look i
just i think it's i i don't think he's
gonna be on the rams next year and
that's another reason maybe to run him
into the ground because it's not like
you're saving him for 20 i think they're
gonna have to have another planet tail
back in 2020 this is a guy and this is
what happens sometimes with running
backs yes you burn very brightly early
in your career right and then for
whatever reason and and this this is the
knee injury that dates back to the acl
tear that he suffered in georgia in 2015
his final year there with the bulldogs
at some point the the candle burns out
and it burns fast if you're a running
back who is being used repeatedly and
heavily like he was a couple of years
ago yeah no exactly right and i i mean
you know hey we know why i mean the
running back position is just a brutal
position you take hits from every angle
so many every game uh but i i think
there is a good chance that he's not
there and the good thing is for a guy
like todd gurley at least he saw a
second contract he was a top 10 pick he
got to see a second contract that's
great he's still talented he's just not
the superstar we saw a few years ago and
i don't think the rams are dead yet
either i think the rams can be a real
pain in the butt for the seattle
seahawks on sunday night i don't look at
this game and go like oh man the
seahawks are going to run away with this
i don't you know they don't run away
with any game oh exactly
that's the thing right they don't
they're not going to blow anybody out no
they're not so you know again it's
that's you're you're talking about one
aaron donald's sack strip fumble or
jalen ramsey getting a pick down in the
red area and all of a sudden you go whoa
how did this happen the rams are up by
10 here with you know seven minutes left
to go uh the seahawks are rolling
there's no doubt about that but the rams
other than the ravens game
we have never seen them really be
dominated that way in the sean mcvay era
that was a rare thing
now the thing that scares me a little is
something you and i have talked about we
both love is the seattle seahawks their
run game can be a little bit bludgeoning
like the ravens and they played these
six offensive linemen right and i do
worry that they're just gonna steamroll
the rams defensive line in front seven
that's not really that big of a group in
general and that would scare me a little
bit if i'm the los angeles rams
yeah i agree with you and you know what
something else occurred to me because
consider the la market dynamics yep the
fact that both of those teams have a
hard time filling their stadiums
exclusively or predominantly with fans
of those teams the fans of the visiting
team even though they don't take over in
the coliseum the same way they take over
where the chargers play this is the
final pete carroll visit to the coliseum
ever chris think about that one
uh that adds a little something to it
definitely
you're right right yeah that's a special
place for him
and and i think a lot of seahawks fans
are going to be in the building on
sunday night i think a lot of rams fans
may have posted their tickets on stubhub
or ticketmaster or whatever the
preferred secondary website is after the
45-6 loss to the ravens like screw it
i'm not going to that game against the
seahawks i know what's coming and uh
so i i'm just i'm curious how that is
going to affect the atmosphere right the
support for both teams and and whether
or not the rams you know the rams feel
like a stranger once again in their own
building and pete carroll may be right
at home but i agree with you i don't
think the seahawks are going to blow
anybody out but they do continue to find
ways they rise to the champion that's
right we'll be talking about that one a
lot more uh tomorrow as well getting you
ready for sunday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports